hey guys I'm off the grid for August but
little-known podcaster Joe Rogan just
did something that's culturally relevant
what is Mar-A-Lago like so sick
I tried to pretend I was like as soon as
I got in there I was like yo this is it
you can tour it no oh I got in somebody
I knew there worked whoa with the trumps
wow they came to my show and that we got
drunk and they're like do you want to
come to Mar-A-Lago I was like yeah I
thought they were full of the next
day they're like all right we'll pick
you up you gotta go past like armed
guards like we got to get this guy on
the list but yeah then you get in there
it's a bunch of old billionaires like
dudes is it a country club or is it just
it's very small it's very Community it's
very small there's like one Spa there's
that big room and he lives there yeah he
lives in like a wing which is so wild
he lives in a place where people can
visit and then everyone sits in that
like Patio Restaurant area and they're
like he might come out today oh my God
he might come outside and everybody look
how beautiful
that's like solid gold Constitution old
rich people money that's pretty that's a
beautiful place welcome to Mar-A-Lago
the crown jewel of Palm Beach it's got
to be a golf course no no golf course
what Long Beach is close to wow look at
that wow close to West Palm right we
should have a showroom it is yeah it is
I thought the Mellow we should do a show
at Marvel logo
we were talking about doing protect our
Parks if Trump would just set us up a
studio yeah don't even say we're there
he would do it just a bunch of palm
trees behind us yeah just just doing it
yeah we didn't have to tell anybody
we're there so your baby's being lit
away from sacrifice just we'll
eventually occasionally you know talk
about Florida yeah
Florida's great dude we had a great meal
last night it was the are you it
was something about I forget what it is
he had like a giant flag in the front of
it and there was like flaws saying your
flag couldn't be that tall so he
elevated the land so he elevated like a
hill to put the flag on so America's
about loopholes it was crazy he's a big
loophole guy
[Music]
you tell him you can't have a flag High
shut the he's like so what is this
stick itself is it stopping planes like
what are we doing Maybe
yeah everyone I mean in that area
everyone loves that guy look at it yeah
you had to elevate the ground oh smart
move it is a good move it's a good hack
it was weird though it was very
uncomfortable in what way just seeing
rich people dudes wearing a Maga hat
it's a weird combination of like formal
dress and baseball and then just a
ridiculous it's true
no one's ever done that before Trump
like in terms of like a politician like
when he was on television he had a bad
hair day just slap on the Omega hat yeah
right we can do yeah you never saw
Reagan in a hat no baseball hat if he
was in it had probably like a like a
cowboy hat let it slide